you don't say squeeze aujourd'hui encore
un nouvel épisode until d'or des jeux
sans humour celui-là il va se passer
plein de trucs mais avant cela tout de
suite le précédemment dont-il doubt
c'était juste une blague ana c'est
aujourd'hui le premier anniversaire de
la mystérieuse disparition de ses filles
anna et baisse washington et je sais à
quel point a et b serait touchée si elle
nous voyait tous réunis ici pour le
rendre la huawei
je crois que quelqu'un se montre un peu
trop amicale boom l'effet papillon
pardon tu as dit quelque chose bien sûr
tu étais trop occupé à faire ta konan
banny pourquoi est-ce que tu irais pas
voir la cabane dont on a parlé tu as
entendu bordel qu'est ce que tu portes
voici notre grille et vers le monde des
esprits
or mais méfiez-vous de josh bien
vraiment si c'est ça que tu veux des ges
ok chapitre iii isolement 8h jusqu'à
l'aube
ces partis [ __ ] ils vont invoquer les
esprits les cons ashley vu que tu es
fraîchement convertis pouvait pas être
notre meilleur aujourd'hui
ok sérieuses allaient non mais l'autre
c'est un blagueur il y aura des blagues
je le sais esprit es tu là te
présenteras tu as nous
si tu es là ça marche pas trop c'est le
blagueur c'est un menteur c'est toi
c'est un menteur c'est un menteur ces
crises c'est lui qu'est-ce que ça
appelle à temps mais comment c'est
possible cette fois qu il bouge ses
crises non on est censé clarifier qui a
besoin d'être dans l'esprit de monde à
l'aide qui est tu es un seul petit nom
c'est la sueur des jo chiffre d'affaires
c'est la soeur de josh auquel son nom
s'écrit s'est créé c'est christine et
sérieuses écrit screen blague je suis
tendu
ah non c'est toi
yes au ch
t'es sûr parce qu'on peut arrêter
je pense que ça peut nous dire s'excuser
ou interroger que tu est il arrivé
interrogé on veut savoir ce qui s'est
passé alors tu nous manques
et on veut savoir ce qui était arrivé tu
peux tu peux nous dire ce qui s'est
passé est rare try to cry ça continue
amer
tu tu es one
[Musique]
il faut qu'on en sache plus là jésus et
je pense que je suis content pas fondées
quitte à tuer
e
preuve aux manettes à la vie bray c'est
quoi ce délire s'est pas créé ce qui
fait une blague c'est qu'est ce que tu
fais blague non normal en même temps il
pense que c'est une blague à sa soeur à
peut pas lui parler comme ça oh là là
[ __ ] ça sent pas bon
mise à jour du statut oye seront bien
sûr mike butin qui a perdu sa copine en
négatif ou exercice les passes et sa
meute en tout ça en effet elle a
vraiment été kidnappé par bruxelles qui
va s'ouvrir dans une cage à un sous type
là comme on a vu tout à l'heure
[ __ ] allez je promets de ne pas signer
la baignade [ __ ] biatch lâche toi que
tu étais barreaux dans le caniveau et
simplement
en plus elle a filmé quoi c'est pas
drôle ah il est blasé michael braun you
and me regardent comme si vous voulez
que je le conseille et que j'étais son
ami
brabeck a gagné au magro c'est pas un
concours mais bon j'ai gagné comme d'hab
ouais abrutis va bientôt deux ans voilà
rien le lui suggérait que selena tu vas
voir non il a une de tes lunettes à
vision nocturne par man mais pas vision
thermique le mec en face à un gars qui
pose pour la cia quoi la paille à la
cabane on y va on y va on la voit lé là
bas allez go go go go go go go go là y'a
quelqu'un à l'eau
dans mauvaise idée et hop là
[Musique]
c'est encore un cerf ils ont quoi les
animaux dans cette forêt ils sont tous
posséder quoi allez on se casse bien que
moi et nous voilà arrivés à la cabane en
amoureux à tort il n'y avait pas de toit
non mais attends ya rien là dedans tout
est mort ici quoi sans déconner ainsi le
masque du mec indices trouvés vieux
masque montrer à je vais être assez
sérieux je vais le montrer par
l'encadrement
c'est par
c'est drôle on arrête
voilà exactement jette le masque et
concentre toi qu'on peut mourir
qu'est ce qu'il fout se sert de merde à
est-ce que c'est sa vision à lui la
vision du psychopathe qu'on a à chaque
fois 2 5 me demande aussi trop de
questions
[Applaudissements]
oh merde
les correctifs
il va pas s'en tirer
mais par quoi calmer le cerf aps de la
psb avant qui leur paraît le pauvre
travail
ça va aller
mike souffre tellement tu veux qu'on
apprécie ce point fut dont pasqua
jacques bien que très bientôt fini c'est
quoi qu'il en soit on n'a pas vu c'est
quoi ça c'est un mec c'est quoi ta
croquer bad
c'est quoi
suivent le chemin ce qui bouge pas moi
je veux pas prendre de raccourcis
dangereux bon gars alors caste sur le
choix
c'est quoi ce truc r2 allez allez tire
le masi [ __ ] trace je suis pas bien on
se rencontre forcément aller le suit de
là dedans et puis c'est toi là dedans
oh là là non mais je te fous de ma
gueule on l'est dont les dons les noms
des gars là on est juste que vous allez
allez quoi papa papa
non mais je veux des kwassas tangente et
d'étudiants suivaient bakiev et fait
péteuse de la part de quoi de plus
normal tu es comme pas mais tu est un
homme de paix tout de même on veut pas
c'est quoi mon gars c'était un ours sans
doute mais mes fesses annoncé quoi
pâture aux noms italiens
on va bien se passer vrai
parce que je suis à peu près sûr que les
ours ne savent pas ouvert les portes
s'ouvraient des voitures coire juste
arrêter ça s'il vous plaît arrêtez sur
internet aura plein de choses sur
internet voilà il n'y a pas de courants
allez salut fis ce qu'on peut se faire
un petit peu quand même pour pas mourir
de froid
c'est pas mal mais des bûches une ou
deux de 2 ou 3 2 donc le qu'une
allumette
y aurait-il une allumette paris à c'est
un truc qui abat voilà comme ça on nous
et puis il y aura le y aura le coin
pourquoi se faire chier c'est parti que
tout va bien
qu'est ce que tu fais ça les lumières et
vivent pas tout casser jouent leurs
bêtes les plombs [ __ ] je l ai je vu
territoire qu'à un corgi c'est drôle ça
bon je vais chercher seul mais dans
cette dans des chambres là bas devaient
avoir un androïde des allumettes la
serge courage je l'aurais jamais dans la
vraie vie ça je vous le dis c est le
maître allait annoncer un bouquin le
kama sutra édité par tain c'est parfait
pour ce petit couple kama ohlala alors
vous allez mettre dans les toilettes
non c'est n'importe quoi ça
la série touch my car il fait tellement
froid ici maintenant que ma langue
resterait comme il y est on m'a jeté
deux buts et tétouan bon j'ai rien
trouvé
ayez du cema tic sur elle alors à
l'appui son téléphone
nike quoi qu'est ce qu'il attend de jeu
34e est inquiète moins bête eyes et
mettez ces juges cela on le voit
derrière j'ai trop dégoûté voilà parfait
hop le petit aller en amoureux
l'épopée des amoureux aux sept saints
alcool ya un [ __ ] j'aimerais bien
faire un faux si ma silva ou quoi mike
les faux nez tu peux les faire mais s'il
te plaît voilà qui sait il n'ya personne
dehors
obama réseau là j'ai l'impression qu'on
nous observent voilà ça me plaît pas
tamer séquelles ou sa bouche avec un
truc qui rassure pas cette femme simone
allez hop c'est légal allez hop ap ap ap
ap ap ap ap tout cela doit dégager
je pense que j'ai un peu peur et c'est
difficile pour moi de tenir bon et à
quoi tenir bon écoute j'ai l'air super
confiante et j'agis comme une bombe
sexuelle et tout mais au fond je vais
être honnête avec toi et moi je m'en
vraiment confiance en moi aulas l'a
loupé le coût de la vie qui a pas de
confiance en elle n'importe quoi je
crois pas une seconde
rassurant indifférent sa manière
compliquée s avère [ __ ] à chaque fois
les autres espèrent bon ils la rassurent
quoi a aucune raison manquer de
confiance en toi arrête si tu savais pas
si j'avais été comme tout le monde
manque tous de confiance en soi mais
c'est de mettre en valeur
c'est peut-être une façade oui à
seulement ouais ouais c'est une dit prêt
et ça c'est non mais il veut juste
l'aspect chaud quoi c'est quoi son
annonce avait pris bien sûr rien relate
uv de complément alors là je proteste de
quoi je vais aussi savoir te mettre un
holà qui peut y aller je suis tout à
tour aux bons ils regardent à travers
les volets on va les voir faire des
choses comme ça c'est habile
actuellement oh là là c'est vraiment un
petit peu parce je sais pas ce que c'est
mais simple je crois c'est un mec qui a
des lunettes à vision des tamales
thermique ou termites
c'est exactement ce qu'on voulait ou aux
idées des glaces et ce au cours sa
chance d'avoir de l'asthme à bordel
alors ça venait de la bonde ou y at il
un carreau cassé alors d'un watt
ça a changé avait pas ça à vos mecs on
est venu juste avant il y avait pas ça
ok je me suis un plus lumière des
affaires elle son nom n'y avait pas ça
il ya un mec qui est venu là il ya
quelqu'un qui est venu là voilà m'être
cassé à calais inquiète tu joues et ya
son téléphone avec de la musique par
terre non mais là c'est le tueur cosy
sûr c'est plus un tour soit l'os iliaque
hui mais de ballades quoi du très très
très minces les fans mais comment c'est
possible alors c'est vrai mais c'est
bien ce qu'a dit quand c'est possible
quoi c'est spécial au bar nous ont
suivis jusque là pour nous [ __ ] la
trouille et juste quand on commençait
deux amis
fana oui bon je pète souza classe elle
provoque une psychopathe
il doit penser qu'elle le traitait
connard
[Musique]
mais c'est la pire de tout quoi
ok elle a fait son cinéma et les
merveilles psychopathe orages et qui
peut tuer au la dent mais puisqu à
oui c'était vraiment que les filles ont
communiqué avec lens bien sûr et leurs
tables de ouija moisi l'appui comme à
vaison des commissions cause des longs
et courts ohlala mais quel épisode
[ __ ] je vous avais dit que ça
commencera ce pimenté à partir des suis
là mais je te suis là et je te suis allé
you're the one eye and the girl you are
the one eye and the girl what's up a toi
ya vraiment un esprit c'est un bouton
c'est une très bonne question ça
concerne les boutons je pense je suis
pas un gars l'ont peu plus
pour secrète c'est j'espère que c'est
une comédie romantique
c'est un problème avec ça a été pas mal
être l'endroit est super vieux bon
est-ce qu'on jette un oeil
allez allez il a fait pas voué aux
tempêtes
allez on y va bonjour non il ya des tas
y avait bien une araignée sur la caméra
police a fait exprès liés aux tests
comme si la dalle après je suis sûr à
une photo des deux soeurs [ __ ] c'est
trop triste quoi c'est beaucoup trop
triste et au doigt et à marquer quoi
rien trouvé je vais les prendre et les
cds comme des pourceaux et arracher leur
peau blanche et douce
c'est ce putin d'année 16 ans attendent
les jolie petite anna est bête watts
protecteur ou honnête
ah ah on lui dit ou pas ah [ __ ] je
sais pas je sais pas j'ai envie de lui
dire j'ai envie de dire je veux pas être
seul à savoir ça bordel je veux son avis
je le son aide
onet honnête aller honnête je crois que
c'est précisément sur le plateau voulait
qu'on trouve celle 1,10 m
menace c'est du sérieux il faut qu'on
trouve choquant on y va on y va on y va
on y va on y va on y va
la cuisine olala mais c'est quoi
allez les bosses ou des profiteurs la
[Musique]
tessoualle on a perdu john a perdu l'eau
what are you c'est qui
[ __ ] ya le tueur ça y est elle est là
on voit vraiment qui est ce mec
[Musique]
que par daniela un masque de clown quoi
ok c'est quoi ce truc un cube 6 puis l'a
bien cool c'est pour une séance de
thérapie et la villa mais tout ce qu'ils
peuvent les paiements en bois but par
des magiciens
bonjour monsieur le psy hockey ah ouais
ok alors entre josh et sabu josh a le
choix qui perdure dès le début quoi moi
j'aime bien sam
parce qu'elle est jolie jazz tout ça
mais j'aimerais pour en faire un sondage
en direct avec vous quitte à choisir sam
parce que josh pourra rien lui arriver
il est trop important voilà c'est je me
réconforte r cette excuse alors entre
humilié mais je préfère largement matt
quoi please emile doumba les steaks
entre crise et à je préfère quand même
crise il est drôle il est marrant et
entre mike et jesse j'ai bien jesse la
vieille fille pouces situé là qui dit
que des conneries qui est très bête ça
fait marrer profitent à leur égard j'ai
un truc qui m'a violée juste un regard
d'un cas entre jamie lee jones josh va
décoder entre mike et h chez pas parce
que hlp finir en couple avec kris donc
je sais pas beuzit h micky les claques
et l'ailleurs
oui dans ce pays savent où aller comme
ça aimez-vous le moins de tout les gens
à emilie bat emilie minimes dessous
emilie elle me supporter ouais ouais
chiante
ok c'est l'as far west on parlera à
l'essai le docteur il
[ __ ] ce [ __ ] de la côte et de
l'afsset ross evry - il envoie les gens
s'il ya pas de ce troisième épisode sur
tille dernier celle-ci vous a plus c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas à aller mais comme
d'habitude les choses commencent à
carrément ce corset voilà il ya la
blonde homme prostitué qui s'est fait
littéralement choper à travers une porte
il ya aussi crise et h qui sont par
terre évanoui le tua qui allume une
bougie qui se balade dans le dans le
chalet et je sens que le prochain
épisode va être encore plus corsée soyez
présents merci d'avoir regardé surtout
très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
tient tout le monde puisse sauver josh
sauvé h les suit
non mais pas écrit devons mourir à sa
trouvent les devants mourir et
j'aimerais juste déçu avant leur mort
non je prenne